okay maybe I'll go into a Stafford
gambits
opponents playing quickly
seemingly confidently
as my staff are about to get refuted
see what move they play here
oh okay so this is
this is a line
hey Eric
hey a tinubu
welcome welcome
[Music]
yeah this is still Pratt this might be
still prep for my opponent too
basically White's played all the top
engine moves so far
engine will give maybe close to plus
four or five here for whites
but it's still tricky like
the pieces that I have left are all
doing something
at Bishop C4
this is such a fun move to play
more secret prep being revealed but this
isn't so Secret
the first instance of this move I think
was from the um this Jonathan schrance
against stockfish video
where he almost beats sockfish with this
move I have shown this many times as
well yeah
actually I had this position against one
of the players in coffee chess
oh my God
because it's one of these lines that if
white has really taken the time to try
and refute the Stafford they might go
into this
but Bishop C4 is one of these um
it's one of these moves that White's
usually not ready for
so Bishop takes C4 I don't think I've
seen before
actually not sure how simple this will
be I could play this
yeah probably 95 is
the best
because Queen takes I think I run out of
fuel
like 92
but at least with 95
okay I'm down
I'm down two Bishops and a pawn
but I'm threading a massive triple Fork
couple that with Rook d8 coming
F3 is attacked twice I have to work on
the second rank
this is why I still play the Saturn
the other day I actually I played
against the saffron
and
I played pretty much exactly what light
played at least early on like the C3
line
opponent played Bishop B6 and
I've had to punish uh punish my
opponents
but now I'm showing
what to do against the supposed
refutation
interesting so whatever white takes back
with I'm gonna take on C5 attacking
the bishop and The Rook
it's still very tricky though
yeah
I think we're still following the
Jonathan trance video too recently
learned leeches automatically draws a
game after it reaches move 300. yeah new
rose and trophy
um
I don't think I would approve that
trophy
in order to do that you basically have
to
cooperate with your opponents
okay I have a choice now
also I'm pretty sure I had this position
against Serana in a title Tuesday once
I could Castle
if I take there's check here here
Queen
it's a question
what to do
I could play key seven as well
I feel like I should
take the pawn
I think I should Castle
wow so now take their
I think I can take here
I've sacrificed so many things this game
like starting with the pawn in the
living stature Gambit and then
like sacking the two pieces I just
sacked The Exchange
but it's all about getting initiative
and now wherever the King goes I can
take here with Chuck
or not with Czech but attacking the rook
in the bishop
that's a move though
so I think I still do this
we'll see Rook h a king
I forgot about that move
I'm still triple attacking these things
objectively it's still probably bad for
black but
and still this long-term nagging
pressure like this Rook has a hard time
entering the game
if I can take here I get a past Pawn
that's a good move though
probably have to do this
Rook D7 King F6
looks to be okay I'm ready to play G6
probably the main idea I also have this
move
looks a bit riskier though
I think I like this better
a G6 traps the bishop
if I'm not mistaken
it's a weird Bishop trap
but do I want to throw in the check
first
probably not because Rook F1 I win The
Rook
and queen also is useful defending the
C7 Pawn
hmm
a very tricky move
I mean I think I've survived like the
worst of the storm
I should be winning this Pawn next
maybe first start with this
so attacking this but also threatening
this
let's take
yeah my king is still in a small
predicament
Chuck
so I want to hide on B6 I guess
check
oh wow I'm almost getting mated not
quite
okay
that was a fun game
that was a
I mean that was like a very
critical line of the Stafford
and it might take some explaining like
this bishop C4 move
I remember when I first saw it it just
seemed like a joke
to put the bishop on the Square where
it's obviously hanging
but we do have to give
credits and kudos
to
Jonathan trance
I am going to perform a little bit of
them yeah the magic trick I am going to
try to hold my own with the Stafford
Gambit against stockfish this was like
the Genesis video this is yeah this is
where he plays Bishop C4
play a brilliant move
the C5
then now you go here and we're trying to
wow so we we followed the exact game
that Jonathan played against stockfish
but wait a minute
this double attack
but now so I've seen this video like
many times but I didn't remember exactly
the line that he reached but apparently
it was exact same and we're gonna see
Rook H upon magically get out of it by
threatening Rook to h8 so we're simply
going to have to cut and counseling is a
move I played it's going to get castled
so my opponent deviated from this game
because he took on F7
while selfishly Bishop F1 I wonder
I wonder how different the moves are
engine still says White's like close to
winning
but Bishop takes F7 was apparently a big
mistake
allowing Rook takes G2
and then
ah
but it's a mistake because back and
forth to draw which I didn't want to
draw this position
so I took on F3 playing for a win and
White's now plus five but why is white
plus five
so this is all good for white
oh Rook D3
freeing the bishop attacking the queen
and if Queen F2 there's Rook D2
yeah and the two Rooks for the or two
Rooks on the bishop for queen
should be winning long term
but white had to play it precisely
yeah these days I imagine stockfish
could
like win this position with white or
just win against this line
but anyway
um
I'll leave a link to the video if this
goes on YouTube I'll link uh this video
in the description as well
so
yeah the staffer Gambit it should be
dead but
there's always more layers of trickiness